as you see some of this playing out
obviously housing is just being
destroyed
yeah what's your read on the housing
market and it just feels
like that's not coming back anytime soon
until they you know put us back sub two
percent or even sub sub one percent
interest rate like what's your read i
mean housing's toast for this economic
cycle right like you know you're not
going to get a significant decline in
rates until you get through recession
and you don't want to be like
housing is not a place that people go
speculate on or even you know um you
know consume from a capital good
perspective interest heading into
recession so we probably have to wait
till we get to the other side of the
real recession um to really think about
housing um but you know you you know a
few statistics i'll throw at you like
you know the leading indicators for
housing are literally like
falling off the map i'm serious like the
the nahb of the national association of
home builders puts out this housing
market index survey it's basically like
the pmi for the housing market more or
less and the the rate i think that the
level it landed on but the the rate of
change the month-over-month decline in
the in the series was the biggest
month-over-month decline in the time
series ever going back to 1985 excluding
uh april of 2020 which was the lockdowns
you got the other leading indicators
like housing starts and building permits
are contracting at down 40 percent
annualized rates of change on a
three-month annualized basis so like i
mean literally the housing market is
like light switch click it's dark i mean
it's serious it's falling off the bottom
of the page the last question i have for
you is recession uh
two negative quarters of gdp growth a
lot of people say it's a recession meets
technical definition uh president united
states he claims it doesn't uh federal
reserve treasury they say that it
doesn't uh
i haven't heard anyone yet ask
explicitly if two negative quarters of
gdp is not a recession then can you
please define recession
because it sounds like their answer
right now would be uh yeah sure the nber
will uh tell you when it's a recession
and when it's not
of which i don't know a single person at
the mber i don't think anyone else in
the world could name someone there uh it
seems to be this like fictional
organization that just like makes [ __ ]
up uh kind of the ministry of truth for
economics um
[Laughter]
i mean that's what
let's just call it what it is right
honestly like we you talk about him it's
like i think of like
seven or eight like very old no offense
to anybody who's not young uh very old
people wearing like baggy
suits from like the 1990s you know like
pocket protectors and like you know very
ill colored shirts and ties and they're
like they've got like ruled line paper
like is this the recession mm-hmm
smoking around cigars do you want to
know the funniest part about this
i'm gonna say something that most people
don't know and they're gonna be like
wait what
when the president of the united states
federal reserve chairman and the
treasury secretary all say
two negative quarters of gdp growth is
not a recession a recession is defined
by the national bureau of economic
research
it makes you me and everyone else
believe that's a government organization
the national bureau of economic research
is a private nonprofit
at what point does the government say
that someone in the private market gets
to decide when there's a [ __ ]
recession or not
right i i i normally would be right
there with you you and i agree on 99.9
of things the only reason i disagree
with you here is because if the if you
allowed the government to determine what
a recession was then there never be any
recessions because no government is ever
going to indict itself and say hey yeah
we we [ __ ] up so bad in the economy
and it turned into a recession like you
know biden is a bit he's been doing sort
of like um you know he's been
backtracking on this and trying to
prepare people for this print for for
weeks now right like you know no no no
sitting uh congress or white house is
ever gonna say we're in recession so i
think this came up back in the you know
maybe in the 50s or the 70s you know
when you we kept having like you know
intermittent recessions and whatnot and
they were like look we got to put this
to the private sector because if we
allow the the government to tell you
they're going to continue lying